I'm not into it I think I think uh both
those chains should just shut up
every taco place has a taco Tuesday
every Taco is like every taco joint has
a taco Tuesday marketing campaign what
are we doing here dude
[Music]
all right have you guys
actually obviously you've heard of Taco
Tuesday
yes who do you think owns a trademark
it's a taco too LeBron James it's a
audible trademark wait who owns that
[__] there is you're probably not gonna
guess but George Lopez it is a rival
apparently imagine if it was right eel
George Lopez apparently a rival to Taco
Bell called Taco John's no [__] way
are you shocked or are you yawning
you looked really shocked
when you said Taco John's
I was gasping for oxygen that's not even
a good rival because I've never heard of
them yeah weren't they based out anyone
had a taco from Taco joke dude Taco Bell
sucks wait what Taco John's I thought
we're all collectively hating on Taco
John's yeah anything's better than Taco
Bell dude taco wands no that's way
better
that's racist dude what do you have
against Taco Bell I just think
especially living in La it's like just
go literally anywhere yeah anywhere else
but they can't make a chalupa have you
been to a food truck and go like hey can
you make me a [__] gordito crunch all
right okay okay
I'll say this I don't know whatever I'm
excited to get a chalupa because I do
like chalupas yeah as soon as I take one
bite and I'm I'm excited with the Sierra
Mist I'm disappointed
I'm like damn it I should have just got
a regular taco or a burrito are you
getting those chalupa with steak though
dude I get the chili boys steak chicken
and [__] ground beef
he said it's so cool dude I get it all I
get all I get the [__] I just I go to
Taco Bell I said let me get the works
and they give me all three damn dude off
menu for me have you ever taken a uncut
quesadilla and wrapped your burrito in
it and then eating it now we're into
sacrilege that is but that's kind of
fire though like I get the quesarito I
like I get it what about the Gordita
Crunch the Gordita Crunch is is solid
but once again as soon as I eat it I'm
bummed what's again
your thoughts are so organized on such a
stupid topic I think about this a lot do
you do you suffer from short-term memory
loss is that why you constantly go back
to Taco Bell no because it's it's I I
recently went because it was like the
only thing that was nearby and I ate
there you're trying to give them the
benefit of the doubt again yeah it was
terrible yeah I was like maybe I'm just
maybe I'm thinking about this the wrong
way
what do you what drink do you pair it
with I I like the drinks as soon as I
get a little I won't get the Baja Blast
because what is that anyway that's gamer
fuel that's [__] a highlighter yes
you know what you shouldn't get because
you don't know what it's about
I love you being defensive
but I like the slushies bro the slushies
at Taco Bell are banging bro they're
banging yeah chalupas are really good
they're they're good for like two bites
and then you're like I made a mistake
and you know what we got it from one did
you get it with sour cream though yeah
it comes with it but you know they have
pockets of hot sauce have you tried
putting that on there the customization
bro I do the whole Taco Bell experience
you guys understand like I take it
seriously like one packet of hot sauce
per bite you're the first Taco Bell here
I've ever met you there's more of them
on the comment below
I find it so shocking that like clearly
just by listening to him Taco Bell has
an amazing reputation like they've done
a lot of things they have big
achievements they have a rival called
Taco John's yeah that we've never heard
of how is that a rival yeah where are
they where's Taco John's located oh back
to the story so uh the taco chain is it
in Bellflower or something
[Laughter]
[Music]
is it like in Nevada Okay so
the whole point of this is that Taco
Bell wants to liberate the taco Tuesday
trademark from the smaller rival chain I
thought Del Taco was rivalry
[Laughter]
I met the fan of Del Taco actually yeah
he's like a your stereotypical cute
adorable light grandpa oh cool good
honestly [__] the story I'm more of a
Del Taco fan as well what Del Taco over
Taco Bell Taco Bell is just not it's
just no because you know why because Del
Taco tries to be Mexican that's the
problem so if I were to eat Del Taco I'm
like I'll go to the taco truck Taco Bell
it's his Tex-Mex fake [__] yeah I don't
know what kind of [__] that is yeah but
it's [__] fake because you live it
because you live in Vegas have you been
to the Del Tacos in Barstow I've been
there a couple times because Joe forces
me they're different
the real the real conversation is
supposed to be King Taco versus tacos
Gavilan oh King Taco can you Taco for
the sauce I'll go King Taco and the
limey carne asada but if I'm getting to
go or if I'm getting delivery your boy's
gone no the real conversation it's
Alberto's or mocha salsa let's keep
according to mocha salsa where I live
they're the creator of the carne asada
fries they're the Creator according to
them they have a banner
are you sure that's what the banner says
why would they lie yeah why would they
like Alberto's and if they're lying they
can't get a battery like why would they
lie number one restaurant voted best
yeah you can't get a banner made if
you're lying because you know Alberto's
and Albertacos and Alfredo's are all the
same I did not know that I honestly do
you know down south there's a Roberto's
riggarbertos Filibertos
I swear
I only lie at nighttime freestyle
rapping
now you're showing off
I only lie at night no but yeah San
Diego Robertos is the famous One in San
Diego that's like the one everyone it's
really good but then they have
Rigoberto's Filibertos Albert you know
obviously so they're just like trying to
capitalize off the Erdos familiarity
pretty much Johnny bertos Johnny burnos
mcbirdos Burger kurdos yeah
during the day like yeah it's not that's
a kid yeah I don't remember it because I
haven't ate it a long time let's go
let's get that for me so do you believe
they're really trying to liberate the
freaking taco Tuesdays I think or they
just want to use it too are they trying
to bite off the point the point is the
history of the phrase was created by
Taco John where it was taco Tuesdays
like two t-w-o-s Tuesdays because he was
trying to increase sales with 99 steel
uh 99 deal for two tacos so it became a
hit taco Tuesday yeah dude I doubt Taco
John how have we never heard of Taco
John's we know everything about them so
so the the copyright and phrase is taco
and then t-w-o today is not not just
okay the name was tweaked to Taco
Tuesday like Wednesday Tuesday yeah um
and then the chain trademarked that
phrase in 1989 yeah because I don't
think you could trade more yeah so they
trademarked no they did the t-u-e they
did okay that's like how they
trademarked BOGO for buy one get one
over at Stride Right yeah so Taco
Tuesday becomes a big hit that like
other places started using it and they
would constantly send out like cease and
desists and stuff like that in order to
have them stop that marketing campaign
because it is a marketing campaign yeah
in its original like you know dude shut
up shut up Taco Tuesday lovers it's so
annoying dude you know on uh Maine and
Garfield there was a Mexican spot 50
cent tacos on Mondays wow when I was in
high school they want to go out of
business you guys that's also like 29
cents at McDonald's but it was yeah we
went there you go there with [__] two
bucks dude you're good to go oh baby bro
we don't even have a Taco John's out
here dude doesn't doesn't a
jack-in-the-box have like a taco yeah
their Taco's awesome tacos are delicious
yeah have you had their bowl the the
spicy taco bowl the mini I didn't have
that but their egg rolls are good too so
good the mini they have a bowl they put
mini tacos in yeah and then they put
some lettuce in to make it like a salad
yeah many tacos those are good too I
haven't had I haven't had uh Jack in the
Box tacos
is it's the closest one is in Colorado
is that freaking for real see that's
[__] wait you guys seen this logo
anywhere oh TJ that's Tijuana that's
some [__] high altitude Tacos yeah
that is not good I'm not in it I'm not
into it I think I think uh both those
chains should just shut up
every Taco [__] place has a taco
Tuesday every Taco is like every taco
joint has a taco Tuesday marketing
campaign what are we doing here dude we
we all know one month from now you're
gonna be visiting Taco Bell and I'm
gonna come back guys Taco John's is
legit I won't shut the [__] up do you
like Chipotle or no bro I like all of it
I like Chipotle then how can you say you
don't like Taco Bell because they're
very different okay I'm not talking
about it I understand when I go to Taco
Bell I know what I'm getting I'm getting
like fast food not real Mexican food
then why are you so disappointed because
it's just not good dude I get a
quesadilla and I'm like how does it have
burnt it has like uh brown marks like
because because they painted on it I
know dude and it's the floppiest [__]
thing I've ever seen because it's not
real [__] Char it's [__] painted
on there I know and I don't like that
dude
bubbles on the chalupa wrap is [__]
fake bubbles they didn't fry that thing
they threw it in some sort of microwave
proprietary microwave
it's for quesarito I love this fast food
according to Dick the person that goes
to a [__] that's not true I know what
you're gonna say it's not even real sex
no [__] I do not wanna dude don't I
would she doesn't love you the example
of Nick going to prostitute's really
weird
I would know it's real sad she doesn't
love you oh I know it's real sad that's
not none of the Taco Bell is real I
understand that but it's still so mad no
I'm not mad but the thing is the
convenience right like it hits at the
right time see that's true that's true
he's been to a brothel she doesn't need
to love you to be convenient you know
Ryan's been to a brothel and he knows
what I'm talking I know real sex it's
like if I went to a prostitute and the
pros the sex that guy from The
Prostitute was just like the wackest sex
I've ever got like that's what that is
it said painted grill lights how about a
nice sex robot yeah that's like that you
know it could be constituted as real sex
yeah but technically it's not how would
a judge constitute it as that's a good
question and that's an answer I don't
have no contest not an attempt minute
video so you're saying like if you had
10 what do you what is it that you were
chalupas look I'm gonna eat it all
you're gonna eat it all but afterwards
I'm gonna be like
no that wasn't that one I get you yeah
there's gonna be a buyer's remark you
went from one bite to throwing it away
to two bites to eat all ten I shove
garbage down my throat all the time
okay I'm not a cus like this is not
Annie eats food
but afterwards I'm just like I wish I
had something else yeah you know I mean
that's how I feel like wobble Grill no
real sex like Quiznos right at that
point that's when I go I should have
just got regular tacos that's how I feel
like Del Taco to be honest Subway tastes
like [__] but when they do heat it it's
not bad it's banging I think I think
Subway's good their cookies taste like
Play-Doh Subway's good when when no one
tells you that it's Subway oh the
cookies
spicy Italians really good there
Subway's not bad when it's free catering
yeah if it's there and you're like oh
okay and I'm starving and it's been a
14-hour day on production yeah right
then the brown lettuce looks kind of
refreshing
and you can't taste the plastic that it
was just in yeah
[Music]